Instructor: The last
example we had stepped, where we
waited for the post to come back
before we actually found the
author, because we needed to
know who the author of the post
was, before we could populate
the author, right? The first
thing needed to happen before
the second thing could happen.
It's sort of a waterfall
approach. But in some cases,
you just want to fire them all
off at the exact same time,
because they're not dependent on
each other, and you want to get
these two things back, or four
things back, as soon as possible.
Here, I've got an example for
weather, where I'm going to
fetch the weather, and it's
going to come back after two
seconds with a temperature of 29,
sunny with clouds. Then I also
want to go get my tweets. The
tweets, I'm not searching based
on weather or anything like that.
They've nothing to do with the
weather, other than I just need
to get these two pieces of data.
This goes back after 500
milliseconds, half a second.
The way that we can do that,
instead of chaining the .thens
together, we say promise.all,
and you pass it an array of
promises, so weather and tweets,
and you call .then against that.
I'm just going to format this
like I like to. Then when that
comes back, we are going to get
responses. Let's take a look
at what those responses are.
One, two, here we go, it took
two seconds to come back. How
come? This one came back after
500 milliseconds. Even if this
one came back immediately --
let's not even put a time out on
it at all -- how come it still
takes two seconds to come back?
Because we're waiting for every
single promise to be resolved
before we run our then. If this
one takes 10 seconds, it's going
to take 10 seconds. It's like
the slowest one will decide how
long these things should
actually take. That's after
two seconds. I open it up, what
have we got? Zero is sunny with
clouds, second one, "I like cake."
You know, from a previous video,
how would we get that into some
sort of sane response? We could
just say, const weather tweets =
responses.
Then
console.log weather and tweets.
Now, we have two separate
variables, one with our weather,
one with our tweets in it, and
we can go ahead and start
populating the data on our
actual home page. Probably
not a good idea to name this
weather and tweets. Why? Because
our promises are named weather
and tweets, so maybe call
weather info and tweets info.
That is an example with
setTimeouts. Let's actually do
some with some real data here.
Let's go comment this out.
We need to APIs. If you work
with an API during the day, I
encourage you to go grab that
API. Otherwise, you can use the
ones I've got right here.
I've got a post promise here,
which is going to go to my blog
and grab all of my latest posts.
We saw that one already. Second,
we have the streetcar promise,
which is going to go and fetch
some data from the Paris transit
system here. We need to
resolve both of those promises,
or they will resolve themselves,
but we need to listen to when
they are both resolved so we'll
say promise.all, and pass it an
array of promises. I'm going to
put that on its own line for
readability. Then we will have a
then, which will give us the
responses. Let's just see
what we have inside that
response. Open that up on my
browser. Actually, by the way,
this is not going to work right
away, because I'm just running
it from my file system right
here, and you know that fetch
only allows for cors. There's no
jsonp or anything like that.
If we want to be working with
the fetch API, you need to be
running it through some sort of
server, so I'm just going to pop
open my browser sync server here.
I'm in promises and I have this
browser sync command here that I
run. Start--directory server...
actually two directories --files.
What this will do is start up a
little server for you and give
you actually the files that are
in this folder. That's nice, you
can do npm install-g browser
sync and you can get that
installed if you don't have any
other way of running a server.
We have the multiple promises.
html, and then we can open up
this, and what have we got here?
An array of two things, well
that makes sense. Open it up.
We got the first response that
comes back form Wes Bos, and we
got the second response that
comes back from the Paris
transit. What's going on here? I
don't see the data. Is it in
body? No, that's a stream. We
actually have this problem here
where we have to convert this
readable stream into json, right?
This is the problem we had on
the first one. How do you do
that with two things? What we
can do is we can return a
promise.all again, and then we
will take each of these things,
which is the responses, and we
can just map over them and call .
json on each one. We'll say
response, and we will return
response.json. Why do we have to
call this res.json? Why can't we
just say json.parse around, res.
body or something like that?
The reason behind that is
because there are many different
types of data that could come
back. I just got the docs here
on mdn and it could come back as
an ArrayBuffer, a blob, which is
cool, because you could fetch
the data from a video or an
image and stream that in.
You can use json or if it's just
text or formed data. Don't just
assume that your APIs or your
AJAX requests are always going
to be json, because it could be
any type of data that we have
there. What is this doing
right here? This response is in
an array, and what does map do?
Map takes every item out of an
array, does something to it, and
then returns a new array.
What we're doing here, is we're
taking the array of responses
and taking each one and calling .
json on it, which returns a
second promise, which we can
then call .then on, and that
should then, responses, that
should give us some real data.
Let's see here, here we go. It
looks like I got 10 posts here,
and then in here we've got some
information. There we go,
information about all of the
transit in Paris. That's
pretty neat. We do promise.all,
we pass it both of our initial
promises. Then when both of
those come back, we run .json on
all of them. When both of those
come back from being turned from
just regular data into json,
which is just instant, that's
very, very fast, then this final
promise then is called and we
can do whatever it is that we
want with that data.